si Santiago Gracias sobre ese ataque se
sabe sin duda que ocurrió en el
asentamiento benévacof en Jerusalén este
ocupado como decías hay confirmados al
menos siete personas muertas cinco
seguro declaradas en el lugar de los
hechos y al menos hay 10 heridos varios
de ellos en estado crítico esto ha
ocurrido en las inmediaciones de una
sinagoga recordemos que estamos al
inicio de la festividad del shabat la
festividad semanal de congregación y
rezo de los judíos por lo que el lugar
de los hechos estaba muy concurrido y lo
que ocurrió es que un atacante llegó con
coche abrió fuego y disparó a la gente
que salía de estas sinagoga del lugar de
ahí huyó hacia betjanina un barrio
palestino y se enfrentó a la policía que
finalmente lo mató y cuya policía ha
identificado precisamente que se trataba
de un residente de Jerusalén este el
atacante esta misma policía encontró el
arma en el lugar de los hechos y ahora
el ataque lo ha calificado como un
ataque terrorista que es lo que ocurre
cuando haya agresiones de palestinos
provenientes de palestinos y la policía
está buscando evidentemente sospechosos
de otros de colaborar a este atacante
mientras que ha desplegado todo un
dispositivo policial de hecho el
ministro de seguridad
israelí de seguridad nacional y tamar
sea dirigido a este lugar de los hechos
mientras que por su parte jamás ha
celebrado este ataque y lo ha comunicado
a través de los altavoces de las
mezquitas en el enclave de la franja de
gaza Aunque por ahora no se sabe quién
si pertenecía al atacante o no a
cualquier grupo armado palestino claro
Hablemos del contexto en el que ocurre
no este hecho porque sucede en medio de
una fuerte escalada de violencia en la
región en las últimas 24 horas
esta escalada que tú bien describías es
habitual desde el año pasado ha ido en
aumento a raíz de las redadas de Israel
en discordia ocupada pero sin duda este
2023 ha ido en incrementos y podía ser
posible esto pero ayer este jueves
realmente fue como el detonante de unas
24 casi 24 horas de Gran violencia a
raíz de una redada israelí en el campo
de refugiados de llenín que como decías
se saldó con la muerte de nueve personas
la mayoría militantes pero también dos
civiles y a raíz de esto ha habido toda
una serie de protestas también en caza
incluido en el enclave y a raíz de
obviamente todo esto durante toda a lo
largo de toda discordia ocupada después
ha proseguido un intercambio de
bombardeos como respuesta
desde el enclave se lanzaron varios
cohetes Israel volvió a responder Así
que como ves entre la redada las
protestas el intercambio de bombardeos
sin duda han ido ha sido
de máxima violencia no se sabe hasta
Cuanto más puede escalar sin duda el
hecho de que la autoridad nacional
Palestina haya cortado la coordinación
en seguridad con Israel no es algo que
vaya a augurar una calma pronta pero por
ahora por ejemplo estamos a las puertas
de que llegue el secretario de Estados
de estado estadounidense Anthony blinken
aquí a Israel y los territorios
palestinos ocupados estados unidos no ha
cancelado esa agenda pero como podemos
escribir con estas con estas últimas 24
horas de violencia sin duda la escalada
está en un máximo punto veremos Cuáles
sean las consecuencias Yanira gracias
por este completísimo reporte de
Jerusalén estaremos ampliando esta
noticia a lo largo de nuestra
continuidad informativa